[Musique]
à
donc christophe dalot 37 ans à la
culture apiculteur dans les eaux de la
caroline bras panon donc la caroline les
eaux ni les moyens ma femme nous les
agricultures et apiculture nous fait re
et 2 e donnant sommes aussi là qu'on
appelle la gauche restera c'est une
manière de planter une manière de
concevoir ses cultures
mais les insectes et la réunion et
efficace à 6 cette manière de planter
cette manière de voir les choses sans
dénaturer ou selon d'autres il est la
grosse et de l'agriculture lié à une
forêt non ferreux ça que tout ce
contexte de dames de plantes que l'on a
des liens ensemble et puisse avoir des
rendements des rendements vraiment une
production agricole dans un premier
temps il faut essayer de comprendre son
environnement
analyser pour intégrer ce que vous
voulez intégrer le dent mais c'est pas
n'importe quoi non plus c'est du végétal
que les adapter aux ce contexte
environnemental dans un bus cacao
il ya besoin sous bois il ya besoin
d'humidité il ya besoin en même temps la
chaleur pour nous pousser dans une forêt
à tout ça à l'instant même de la vanille
parce que c'est les mêmes conditions
pédoclimatiques le cacao ilicic se sont
fait qu'on nous veut faire c'est un
rituel patrimoniale pour emmener dia
irs1 une activité économique
ici aussi nous fait de l'apiculture déjà
les abeilles dans un environnement
exceptionnel
donc le mieux que les issues 10 et suis
ici il ya beaucoup de propriétés des
âmes endémique et d'hygiène et
médicinales que 90 de notre forêt est
censé abella de l'afrique nous n'a
aujourd'hui il existera a pu
malheureusement c'est abel elle est
essentielle à nous aujourd'hui me fais
le métier d'agriculteur c'est déjà pas
passion et par parent engagement une
série 1 parce que même été par ati pour
devenir footballeur professionnel est
aussi bine parallèlement comptable m'a
fait une ambition métropole et cet avc
dans en fait la bouleverse toute ma vie
mettez j'ai déjà football d'un très bon
niveau
mon agressivité sur nous sur un terrain
football pour reconstruire en main m'a
obligé à l'est du puits zle
puis-je au plus profond de moi même
constamment avez besoin de quoi me tva
et comment lutter veut faire les choses
on pourrait dire que c'est cette forêt
clair la trouvant - et non pas qu'on la
trouve ali parce que tout ce que vous
avez besoin de ma vie pour partager pour
transmettre pouvoir faire découvrir aux
gens que ça ne paie nana et que ça nous
peut avoir ni même à l'intérieur on
retrouve annie ici mais très
sensibilisés à aux porteurs de handicap
- minute où je rejoue aussi pour
justement que ces personnes ne puissent
avoir un métier est de former parce que
même les reconnaîtra mais handicapé avec
ak op nous travaillons avec la lève pas
pour faire en sorte que l'un des jeunes
des moins jeunes puissent avoir un
contrat pour insérer dans la vie
professionnelle
mais au-delà de ça moi me voudrait faire
en sorte que ma plantation noah que des
pc un handicap que ces personnels
puissent venir se ressourcer
parce qu'avec ce qu'on a subi moins six
est fréquent la permettra - 2 reçoit sa
main de reprendre confiance en moins et
surtout d'être moi même et mes vu ses
chances que la ville a offert une vue
offert cette chance là à deux personnes
qu'elle n'a pas eu pour l'instant voilà
il finit cette seconde villa ben
pleinement mais surtout pour les autres
si c'est ça c'est ça qu'il veut faire
la foraine a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup choses que vous étiez
ce type ne même pas connaître tellement
il est fort près de soi même